Hello and welcome.
It's September 18, 2023,
and it's active. Guest stream 57.1
with Andy Keller. We're going to be
talking about natural neural structure
for artificial intelligence. There will
be a presentation followed by a
discussion. So if you're watching live,
please feel free to write questions in
the live chat. Otherwise, thank you
Andy, for this. Really looking forward
to it and to you for the presentation.
Yeah, thanks so much. Thanks for having
me. I'm super excited to be able to
present this stuff with Active Inference
group. I'm a fan and very interested,
so. Hopefully. Get to
have a good discussion and see what you
guys think about it. So my name is Andy.
I'm finishing up my PhD, supervised by
Maxwelling at the University of
Amsterdam, starting a postdoc at Harvard
after this. So I'll start out just
talking about the goal of my work in
general is to try to bring modern
artificial intelligence closer to more
human like generalization. And so what
we mean by this is maybe some sort of
structured generalization or maybe more
familiar to the active inference
community, like a structured world model
which we believe that humans have. And
the way that we propose to do this is by
integrating natural neural structure
into artificial intelligence. So first
let's define what we mean by structured
generalization. So I think it's fairly
uncontroversial to say that modern
machine learning generalizes beyond its
training sets in the traditional sense.
So for example, even the earliest
artificial neural networks, multilayer
perceptrons, could be trained on data
sets of images like this and achieve
high accuracy. Then, when they're
presented with a held out test set of
images that they've never seen before,
they can still classify them relatively
easily with the same level of accuracy.
And this is what we typically call
generalization. However, even fairly
early on it was noticed that these
systems really struggle with small
shifts or deformations applied to the
images. For example, if so,
you think, why is this surprising? And I
argue it's really due to our innate
ability to perform this type of
structured generalization that this
example is a failure of. So for example,
this shift is nearly imperceptible to us
and we handle it automatically, whereas
in these systems it's very clearly a
major problem. So in words, we can say
that structure generalization is a
generalization to some symmetry
transformations of the input, or in this
case, the symmetry transformation is a
small shift that leaves the digit class
unchanged. So the obvious question then
is what precisely do we mean by this
natural structure and why do we think
that. This would help us with these
settings? So first, let's talk about
what we mean by natural neural
structure. One way to talk about
structure or any type of bias in a
system is an inductive bias. And so an
inductive bias can loosely be defined as
an apriori restriction of a set of
realizable hypotheses. When you're doing
model selection. More colloquially, we
can call this something like before
seeing any data, it's a restriction of
what and how you can learn. So very
broadly, this can include anything from
model class to optimization procedures
or even hyperparameters. And in some
sense they really define what
is possible to learn. And it defines
generalization in that you actually
can't generalize beyond a training set
without having some inductive biases.
And this is explained more thoroughly
in. This paper by David Wolford. So what
we mean by natural inductive biases then
is biases that stem from the
restrictions and limitations that are
faced by natural systems, by the nature
of having to live in the real world.
For example, the brain has many
efficiency constraints and physical
constraints by nature of its
construction. And following this logic,
then these constraints are really
playing some role in our generalization
abilities which currently exceed modern
artificial intelligence. As we'll go
into next. So in this talk, I'll be
focusing specifically on two types of
structure which my work has studied.
These are topographic organization and
spatiotemporal dynamics. And before I go
into my work, I'll give a short example
for why I believe that natural structure
may be useful to achieve the structure
generalization that. I was talking about
before. So the first example comes from
Fukushima's neocognitron architecture
from the 1980s, which was actually built
to directly address the problem of
robustness to these small shifts in
deformation. So in the paper he writes
about inspiration from pupil and
weasel's measurements of hierarchy and
pooling in order to achieve robustness
to these distortions. And so if you look
at the figure he writes u sub s one, U
sub C one and these stand for simple and
complex cells. And so this is a fairly
radical approach at the time, but it
really served to improve robustness and
shifts that were plaguing these early
artificial neural networks. And over
time these ideas were simplified and
abstracted and obviously yielded the
convolutional neural networks that we
know today, which ultimately drove the
success of the Deep Learning Revolution.
So this is really an example of a
natural inductive bias which achieved
structured generalization. So for our
research, it's really of utmost interest
to try and understand what makes these
models work so well and see if this
principle can potentially be generalized
to cover more abstract transformations
and symmetries.
So what makes a convolution achieve this
structure generalization? Intuitively,
you can see this is done by applying the
same filter or feature extractor at
various spatial locations. So here we
see a single convolutional filter being
applied at all locations of an image.
This means that no matter where your
input is, whether it's kind of in the
middle of the image or on the right,
you'll have the exact same features,
with one exception, they'll be
equivalently shifted. So mathematically,
this type of a mapping is called a
homomorphism. It preserves the algebraic
structure of the input space and the
output space. In this case, it's with
respect to translation. And at a simple
level, something like that will be
important to remember for the rest of
this talk is that we can verify
homomorphisms of our feature extractor
if we can see that there's this
commutation with the transformation,
this commutative diagram. And so we can
write this also algebraically by showing
that the feature extractor f commutes
with the transformation operator T. And
basically what we want is there to be no
difference between first extracting the
features and then performing the
transformation, or performing the
transformation and then extracting the
features. So the challenges to date is
we don't really know how to construct
homomorphisms with respect to more
complex transformations that we see in
the real world. For example, our brain
is able to handle changes in lighting
and season naturally. So here
we see lighting on a person's face or
the change of seasons. We can tell it's
the same face or the same road. But we
don't know how to build models which
respect these transformations. And so it
makes us hard to build systems which
handle them in a robust and predictable
way. To give an even more abstract
example of what I mean by this and the
potential negative repercussions of
models which don't handle symmetry
transformations, consider modern text to
image generation programs. So in this
example, I asked Dolly Two to generate
image of a teddy bear on the Moon. And
it does this incredibly well, right?
Probably better than I could. It has
texture fur, incredibly detailed.
However, if I ask it to do something
which I see as conceptually simpler,
such as draw a blue cube on top of a red
cube, it fails to do this. And to me
this seems unintuitive since the second
task seems significantly easier.
But what I'm arguing is that the reason
that this is surprising is precisely the
same reason that the MNS translation
example was surprising. There is this
symmetry transformation happening here,
namely the transformation between these
complex objects of a teddy bear and the
Moon and these simple objects of cubes
which we intuitively expect the network
to be able to handle and respect. And we
see that it doesn't. So just like how
Fukushima's work showed that these
natural structure of hierarchy and
pooling of our visual system are
effective for making generalizations to
small transformations, I argue that
potentially higher level structure may
be necessary to fix these abstract
generalization problems. And so the
question then that I'm studying and that
I'm asking is what might this structure
be and how do we implement this in an
artificial neural network architecture
that can actually be used for performing
computation?
So, to begin to answer that, I'll jump
into my first line of work on
topographic organization. So topographic
organization is observed widely
throughout the brain from primary visual
cortex to higher level areas. And it can
very loosely be described as this
property that neurons which are close to
one another tend to respond to similar
things. For example, on the left we show
the color coded preference of each
neuron in the Macaque primary visual
cortex as a response to oriented lines
and we see this smoothly varying set of
selectivities. Another type of
organization is known as retinotopic
organization where nearby neurons in the
visual cortex tend to respond to nearby
receptive fields. However, this
organization isn't limited to these low
level features. It extends to more
complex features such as those present
in faces or objects or places. And this
relates to the so called functionally
specific areas of the brain such as the
fusiform face area FFA and the
perihepocampal place area PPA.
So in this work, the main idea again is
that perhaps this topographic
organization in some sense which is
intimately related to the convolution
operation and Fukushima's architecture
we can maybe generalize the benefits of
this to more abstract transformations in
other words, learn how to build more
complex homomorphisms that we can't do
analytically right now. So just
to show that we're not completely insane
with this idea there is some prior work
in this domain from people such as Honin
Yanlaka Apohevarnan in the early ninety
s and two thousand s and they studied
how topographic organization may be
useful for learning invariances mostly
in linear models. So the question for us
when we entered this space is what is
the most scalable abstract mechanism
that can be leveraged from these
approaches which we can integrate into
modern deep neural network
architectures? And ultimately we settled
on a generative modeling approach which
I think might be interesting to the
people in this community which then
allows us to relate it more closely to
topographic independent component
analysis with the basic idea being that
we can learn a topographic feature space
by imposing a topographic prior
distribution over our latent variables.
So just to give a brief background I
assume most people are already familiar
with this but the kind of general
assumption is that the brain is a
generative model and this idea in some
sense can be attributed to Helmholtz
from the 19th century where he said that
what we see is the solution to a
computational problem. Our brains
compute the most likely causes from
photon absorptions within our eyes. And
so as an example, if I show you this
image you immediately recognize it as a
globe with some curvature. However, it
could just as equally be a disk with a
distorted perspective on it. So this is
how we get optical illusions or our
images. So like this one, your brain
infers that there is a cube here because
of the structure but really it's just.
A flat piece of paper. So you can think
of this generative model aspect as kind
of like an inverse graphics program. In
the program, the abstract properties of
the sphere are known the position, the
size, the lighting and these are used to
project the sphere to create the 2D
image that is rendered. So in effect,
what Helmholtz and others are saying is
that as a generative model, the brain is
actually trying to invert this
generative process and doing inference
and infer the underlying causes of our
sensations. So the reason I'm kind of
belaboring this point is that there's a
lot of talk of generative models today,
and I'm not necessarily just talking
about generating images or pretty
pictures. I really want to mean a
framework for unsupervised learning.
So then to get a little bit more into
the details, what do I mean by a
topographic prior? So generative models
are typically described as a joint
distribution over observations, x and
latent variables, which we'll call Z.
And this is typically factorized, or one
way that this is done is factorized in
terms of a prior p of Z. And this true
generative model conditional generative
model p of X given Z. And so one way
that we can think about this is that the
prior can be seen to encode relative
penalties for each type of code that is
produced. When we invert our generative
model, this is called computing the
posterior e of Z given X.
And so to develop a topographic latent
space, we want to introduce some sort of
a topographic prior, which this
topographic ICA work showed is
equivalent to something like a group
sparsity penalty. So people might be
familiar with typical sparsity penalties
from independent component analysis.
You want your activations to be sparse,
meaning many of them are zero. So that
could look something like this. You have
a bunch of blue squares that are active,
but most of them are not active. But
specifically, with a group sparsity
penalty, we want these priors to assign
lower probability to these distributed
sparse activations and higher
probability to these grouped, densely
packed representations. You can also
think of this like a higher penalty when
things are spread out, a lower penalty
when things are closer together. So
again, this can be written abstractly
like this. But I want to make clear that
each one of these squares here
represents kind of a neuron in our
model. And they're organized in this 2D
grid. So when we're talking about
grouping, we really mean grouping in
that 2D topology. So one thing that's
really interesting and kind of important
is that these priors don't just give us
topographic organization, but they've
also been noted by people or studied by
people like Erosimicelli and Bruno
Olshausen to actually fit the statistics
of natural data better, specifically
natural images. They've shown that using
this type of a prior, you actually get a
sparser set of activations, meaning that
the prior fits the true generative
process a little bit better. And as
we're aware, the brain has a high degree
of sparsity and this is believed to be
very relevant for efficiency.
So to get a little bit more into the
details, to implement this type of a
group sparse prior, we use a
hierarchical generative model and this
is basically introduced by some of the
topographic ICA work. The idea
is that you have a higher level latent
variable U which simultaneously
regulates the variance of multiple lower
level variables T. And this is how we
get group sparsity. Then to get
topographic organization, you can have
multiple of these latent variables U
slightly overlapping with their fields
of influence. So their neighborhoods,
we can call them, and this will give you
this smooth correlation structure you're
after. So get the intuition for this.
You see that this variable T over down
on the bottom here is not getting any
input from this U on the top, but it is
sharing a U variable with this T in the
middle. So it's like they're sharing
variance, they're sharing some
components with their neighbors, but not
all components. And that's really due to
this local connectivity of these higher
level variables U. So to
keep it simple about how we use this
generative model, let's go back to a
single U variable. And the challenge in
this type of an architecture which made
it difficult for many years is how
do you infer the approximate posterior
over these intermediate latent variables
in this hierarchical architecture? This
is not super straightforward. So prior
works have used heuristics developed for
linear models. And in our work we found
that this really didn't extend to modern
neural network architectures. So really
our insight is to leverage a
factorization, a specific
reprometerization of this distribution.
And so this reprimmatrization
specifically is achieved by defining the
prior to be what's known as a Gaussian
scale mixture, meaning that our
conditional distribution of T given U is
actually a normal distribution where the
variance is defined by this variable U.
And for certain choices of U, this
distribution is indeed sparse and
encompasses a range of distributions
such as Laplacians and student T
distributions. One way of defining it is
a Gaussian scale mixture admits a
particular repromaturization in terms of
independent gaussian random variables Z
and U. So specifically, then we see that
this T variable, which was originally
fairly complex, is actually just a
product of a bunch of gaussian random
variables which we now know how to work
with much more efficiently in generative
models. And specifically what we're
going to do is so that we can actually
get approximate posteriors for U and Z
separately and then do a deterministic
combination of them in order to compute
our topographic. Variable T. And this is
much easier to do. So, without going
into too many details, the method that
we decide to use is what's known as a
variational auto encoder, which
leverages techniques from variational
inference to derive a lower bound on the
likelihood, allowing us to parameterize
these approximate posteriors with
powerful nonlinear deep neural networks
and optimize them with gradient descent.
This is going to be familiar to the
active inference community. But really
what we've done is instead of having a
single encoder and decoder. As is
typical Bayes, we now have two encoders,
one for U and one for Z separately. And
then we combine them in this
deterministic manner to construct our
topographic T variable. If you see that
this is actually the construction of a
student's T distribution from Gaussians
and then we do this before decoding
and then maximize the likelihood. Of the
data altogether. So this is the elbow,
the evidence lower bound abound on the
likelihood of the data and is actually
very similar to the variational free
energy that is. Used in the active
inference community. So with
these details out of the way, what's
really interesting is what happens when
we train this generative model which has
relatively simple group sparsity penalty
in its latent space. And we want to look
at kind of what it's learning in terms
of. Its organization of features. And
first we start with the simplest
possible data set. We have a black
background with white squares at random
XY locations. If we train our auto
encoder with this group sparsity penalty
on it and then we look at the weight
vectors of our decoder which we're
plotting in blue here, again organized
in this 2D grid, we see that indeed
they learn to be organized according to
spatial location. So this can be seen as
similar to convolutional receptive
fields where the receptive field of each
neuron is really given by the kind
of inputs at its location.
And this makes sense intuitively from
the group sparsity perspective since for
any given region, which we highlight,
like in yellow here, the filters in a
given group are much more highly
correlated. They have these overlapping
receptive fields than other random
locations. So essentially we see that
our model is learning to cluster
activities together in sort of a
simulated cortical sheet according to
the correlations in the data set. So
instead of in convolution where you're
actually doing weight tying and you're
manually specifying I want to copy this
weight everywhere, you can maybe think
of this as like approximate weight
tying. And really we're learning this
from the correlation structure of the
data set itself. And just to give a
little bit more of a biological
inspiration for this, we know that
retinotopy is present in the brain.
This is an example of retinotopy and the
Macaque visual cortex. And you can see
if you show the Macaque an image like
this, it gets projected into this
topology preserving space actually on
the surface of the cortex. So the idea
is that topographic organization and
even learn topographic organization is
preserving the input correlations of our
data set.
And potentially this may be beneficial
for generalizing these ideas a little
bit further. So like I said at the
beginning, it would be even better if we
could just learn something more than
just convolution, maybe more complicated
equivalences. So how do we do that?
One thing that's clear in natural
intelligence is that we don't exist in
this world of IID frames, right? We
exist in a world of continuous sequences
of transformations. So maybe we can
extend our model to this setting to
learn, observe transformations. This is
the idea of temporal coherence.
So what would happen if we just simply
extended our previous framework over the
time dimension, right? So instead of
just grouping, saying we want our
neurons to be group sparse in terms of
spatial extent on the cortex, we
actually want them to be group sparse
over time. Meaning that if one set of
neurons is active now, we want that same
set of neurons to be active into. The
future as well. If we kind of
intuitively think about this, we see
that this is actually more encouraging
invariance than equivariance. A way to
understand this is we're saying we want
the same neurons to be active
constantly, but the input transformation
is changing, right? The feet of this
little fox are moving. So if the same
neurons are coding for the same thing
over and over again, but the feet are
moving, those neurons are going to learn
to be invariant to the motion of that
leg. Of this dog, for example. So
instead is that. I went the
wrong way here.
So instead, our insight was that this
group Sarcity could instead be shifted
with respect to time. So this would mean
that sequentially shifted sets of
activations would be encouraged to
activate together, and then our latent
space would really be structured with
respect to the observed transformations.
So you can see here that rather than the
same set of neurons being active at all
time steps, it's really a sequentially
permuted set of neurons that we're
grouping together in this sparse way.
And then this allows us to model
different observations over time, but
they're still connected in terms of
learning a transformation and preserving
this correlation structure of the input
data set. So if we put this together
into our topographic BAE architecture,
you can get something that looks like
this. You see that we have an input
sequence. We're again encoding a Z
variable and then multiple U variables
in the denominator here. And then each
one of these U variables is shifted kind
of like we were showing before. In order
to achieve this shift equivalent.
Structure that we're looking for. When
we combine these in this student T
product distribution, we get a single
latent variable. This is now our
topographic latent variable T. And now
that we have this known structure in our
latent space, you can think of it like a
structured world model. We know how to
transform this latent space. In this
case, it's by permuting these
activations around these circles, doing
like a cyclic roll, a cyclic shift. We
know that this is going to correspond to
our learned input transformations. And
we can verify that by saying, okay,
what if I continue this input
transformation, the true transformation
in the data set, which is a rotation.
And then I compare that with how I've
done my role in my latent space by
moving my activations around in my
brain. And then we decode and we see
that we get the exact same thing. And so
this is demonstrating this commutivity
property that I was talking about before
for verifying homomorphism. And so
to measure this a little bit more
quantitatively, we can measure what's
called an equivalence loss. So this is
really the quantification of this
difference between our rolled capsule
activation, our rolling in our head,
versus watching the rolling unfold,
watching the transformation unfold
before us. So we see that topographic
VAE achieves significantly lower
equivalent error. This bubble VAE is
what I was talking about before, where
it's learning invariance, so it doesn't
have the shift operation and then the
traditional VAE kind of has no notion of
organization or temporal. Component, so
it performs very poorly. In addition to
this, we see that the model is a better
generative model of sequences. It just
gets a lower negative log likelihood
on the data set. So it's better able to
model this data set because it has a
notion. Of the structure of the
transformations.
We can test this on multiple different
transformation types. On the top row
we're showing the true transformation,
we hold out these grayed out images and
then on the bottom row we encode and
then we just kind of roll our
activations around and we keep decoding
to see what the model has
learned as the current transformation
that's being observed. And we see that
it can basically perfectly reconstruct
these elements of the sequence that it's
never seen before. Additionally, with
images that are from the test set that
it's never seen before, simply because
it knows what the transformation is that
it's currently encoding and it. Can
generalize that to new examples.
So the takeaway from this part is really
topographic organization. We showed that
it preserved input structure and now
we're showing it can potentially improve
efficiency and generalization as we
would hope. So, finally, something that
surprised us and I thought was
potentially the most interesting is that
these transformations that are learned
by our model actually generalize the
combinations of transformations that
were not seen during training. So, for
example, despite only training on color
and rotation transformations in
isolation, if the model is presented
with a combined color rotation
transformation at test time, we see that
it's able to completely model and
complete these transformations perfectly
through the capsule role, implying that
it's learned to factorize represent to
these different transformations and it
can flexibly combine them at inference
time. So again,
maybe we also don't just get efficiency
and generalization, we also get some
basic compositionality.
So let's talk about the limitations and
what we could do next. The main
limitation is that there's a predefined
transformation that we're imposing in
both space and time. So although we
freed ourselves from group
transformations and specifically like
translation or rotation as is currently
done in the machine learning world. We
still have this hard coded
latent role in our heads for everything
we see. And to make this a little bit
more flexible, so hopefully we can model
a greater diversity of transformations,
we think maybe we can take inspiration
from more structured spatiotemporal
dynamics that are observed in the brain.
And so that takes us to the second part
of this talk, which is spatiotemporal
dynamics that we're going to try. To
integrate into artificial neural
networks. One example of that is
traveling waves. Like I show here. So
what do we mean by that? Here's a very
recent paper where they used a nine
tesla fMRI operating at 36 millisecond
resolution to image a single slice of a
rat brain under anesthesia. And what we
see is this very clearly structured
spatiotemporal activity and
correlations. And these authors of the
paper go on to analyze this activity in
terms of the principal modes as depicted
on the right. So our hypothesis is that
perhaps some sort of a correlation
structure like this may be beneficial
for structuring the representations of
our model with respect to observed
transformations, but in a much more
flexible way than simply just a cyclic
shift. Like we were doing before.
And let me say that this is not just
observed in anesthesized rats.
You can see these traveling waves happen
in the mt cortex of awake behaving
primates. So for example, on the left
here, they show traveling waves that
actually change how likely a
primate is to see a low contrast stimuli
based on the phase of the wave.
Furthermore, they show that a high
contrast stimulus on the right can
induce a traveling wave of activity that
propagates outwards union primary visual
cortex. So these are really ubiquitous
throughout the brain at multiple levels.
And it would be interesting to study
what their implications are for
structured representation learning. In
our case, or generally, there is prior
work which has studied these types of
dynamics and they built models. So on
the top, these are the equations which
describe a spiking neural network,
which they show if you implement time
delays, actually exxonal time delays
between neurons, you do get these
structured dynamics of traveling waves
as long as your network size is large
enough. However, as many
people probably know, it's relatively
challenging to train spiking neural
networks of the same size and
performance as deep neural networks.
Similarly, on the bottom, another system
which is significantly simpler, but
perhaps too simple, is a network of
coupled oscillators. These are known to
exhibit synchrony and spatial temporal
dynamics and complex patterns. But this
is called like a phase reduced system
and doesn't quite capture the full
complexity that we're interested in. So
we're looking at something that's
potentially in between these two. And
what we settled on is this work, in this
work is to parameterize a network of
coupled oscillators slightly more
flexibly than a Kuramoto model. So this.
Is really built on this coupled
distillatory recurrent neural network of
Constantine, Rouge and Nisha,
where they basically took the equation
which describes a simple harmonic
oscillator. It's a second order
differential equation. The acceleration
on a ball on a spring is proportional to
its displacement. You can
add additional terms such as damping so
that the oscillations slowly die out
over time. You can drive this oscillator
with an external input to kind of
counteract this damping or to give
slightly more complexity to the
dynamics. And then furthermore, if you
have many of these oscillators, you can
couple them together with these coupling
matrices W, as we demonstrate kind of in
this picture here. So you can really
think of this network as a bunch of
balls on springs and they're maybe
connected to each other also by springs
or elastic bands, whatever. The couple,
the Silatory recurrent neural network of
Rush and Mishra with these various
terms. And this has been shown to be
very powerful for modeling long
sequences. They also mentioned they were
inspired by the brain building this.
And there's a lot of good analysis in
that paper. For example, they show that
this has really beneficial properties
with respect to vanishing gradient
problems that typically happen in
recurrent neural networks. But if we
want to look at spatiotemporal dynamics
in this type of a model, it's slightly
challenging because these coupling
matrices here, the W's that
connect each oscillator's position to
one another, these are densely connected
matrices like I've tried to. Depict on
the left here. So if you try to
visualize the dynamics of this network,
you don't see any spatial organization.
There's no inherent topology to the
latent. Space of this model. So you can
think of this like in our previous
example. A neuron is connected to a
potentially arbitrary set of other
neurons. Those neurons are connected to
another arbitrary set of neurons. And
you'll just get oscillatory dynamics,
certainly, but kind of fluctuations that
don't make a lot of structured sense in
our work. Then we thought, okay, how can
we convert this more to the types of
dynamics that we're interested in, this
structured propagation of activity? And
one clear way to do that is to have a
more structured connectivity matrix W,
which we found is easily implemented and
efficiently implemented through a
convolution operation, which you can
think of like a locally connected layer.
So instead of having every neuron
connected to every neuron, neurons are
just connected to their nearby
neighbors. After training, you'll end up
getting something. That looks like a
smooth spatial temporal dynamics. So to
be a little bit more clear, to train
this model, we take this second order
differential equation that we were
describing before you discretize it into
two first order equations. You can think
of this as like numerically integrating
the ode. We now have a velocity and then
we update and we can train this model
as something like an auto encoder or an
autoregressive model. So we take an
input, we encode it to our latent space.
Really, the input is this F of x term
which acts as the driving term. So it's
like driving these oscillators from the
bottom and then they have their own
dynamics which are defined by the
coupling terms, these local couplings.
And then at each time step we take this
latent state, this wave state, and we
decode to try and reconstruct the input.
Maybe at the current time step or a
future time step, we can do some
analysis of these models during training
to see what happens before training.
And after training, we can compute the
phase and the velocity of the dynamics
in the latent space. Basically, we see
at the beginning of training there's no
waves in our model. But after training,
after 50 epochs, we see that there's
these smooth structured activity
propagating downwards in service of this
sequence modeling task that we're doing,
like rotating objects. So what's the
benefit of this? I mean, the whole
reason I motivated this was to say we
wanted to have more flexibly learned
structure. Are we actually doing that or
are. We just getting pretty waves? So
what we showed in our paper is that we
really are learning some sort of useful
structure. And the way we showed that
is, again, with something like this
commutative diagram. If you take an
input and you encode it and you get a
wave state and then you propagate waves
artificially in that wave state and then
decode, you can observe that it's
actually exactly the same as if you had
just by showing a bunch of different
images of different transformations. So
a lot of different digits, different
features. And we see that we get
different types of wave activity in each
case in order to model that different
transformation. If we train it on
different data sets as well, we
similarly see more complex dynamics. In
this case, maybe not even traveling
waves or standing waves, which can be
thought of as traveling waves in
opposite directions. So we see if we're
modeling these orbital dynamics, we get
these kind of smoothly moving blobs of
activity in our latent space. If we're
modeling a pendulum, we similarly get
kind of complex oscillatory activity so
it's preserved input structure, but
additionally more flexibility than we
had before, which is kind of our
ultimate goal. So finally,
I want to talk a bit about how I think
the outcome of this research may not
only improve artificial intelligence,
but also how it helps us understand why
our measurements of the brain look the
way they do. So to give a brief example
of what I mean by this, I talked a bit
about before, about these and places.
So in this fantastic work with HIE Gao,
we studied if our simple topographic
prior, as we discussed, may be able to
reproduce these same effects. So
specifically, we plot the value of this
Cohen's D selectivity metric for each of
our neurons with respect to a different
data set of images potentially
containing just faces or just objects or
bodies. And so we measure for every
neuron, is it more likely to respond to
faces or the ration emerges in the
brain? But I do think that it tells us
that the relative organization of
selectivity may at least be partially
attributable to correlation statistics
in the data after being passed through a
highly nonlinear future extractor. Such
as a deep neural network. So, in a
similar vein, something that's
interesting, there's a known what's
called tripartite, or the visual stream.
So images of or
objects are selectivity with respect to
objects is organized by more abstract
properties, such as animacy, is this
thing alive or inanimate versus also
real world object size, like what is the
size of a teapot versus a car?
And what we see is that in humans,
this selectivity is organized in this
tripartite structure. You typically have
small objects that are in between
animate and inanimate objects in terms
of their selectivity. And we see the
same thing kind of happens here. So
these are measuring the selectivity of
the same set of neurons, but with
respect to these different sets of
stimuli. We see that the small cluster
is in between animate and inanimate
cluster. And again, this happens for
multiple different initializations. So
this is something I hope we can explore
a bit further for this community. I
think it's interesting because it's
really a way of showing that we built a
structured world model. And potentially,
this world model is beneficial for
better representing real world data in.
A structured way, and you get lower free
energy in that sense. So by
developing these models like we showed
here, we may get insights into new
mechanisms for how this structure
emerges, including topographic
organization that we never thought of
before. So, machine model, I was looking
at the orientation selectivity of
neurons, which I wasn't particularly
expecting something to happen, but
you're looking at kind of these waves
propagate over this simulated vertical
surface. And I thought, okay, maybe I'm
showing rotated images. Maybe this has
some effect on the orientation
selectivity. And actually, if you go in
and you measure the selectivity of each
neuron with respect to these differently
oriented lines, what you see is that
it's surprisingly reminiscent of the
orient paper columns that are seen in
primary visual cortex. This is stuff
going back to Hugle and Weasel. And this
is something that just kind of came out
of this model and the fact that it has
the spatial. Temporal structure with
respect to transformation. So, of
course, this is a really coarse analogy,
but I think this is an example of how
building these types of models can help
us think about how the brain builds
representational structure and the way
it's organized in a way. That maybe we
haven't thought about before.
I think I'm not the only one who's doing
this type of work. And so I want to talk
a little bit about some other people who
are doing this. So I've been talking
about this equivalent structure. People
such as James Whittington and Tim
Barrons and Surge Anguli have
shown recently that by introducing
algebraic constraints into
a learning process, in this case, it was
like the motion of an agent in
an environment. By saying, you need to
preserve kind of this algebraic
structure of if I move in a circle west,
north, east, south, I end up back at the
same point. Again, by introducing these
types of constraints, you get the
emergence of grid, cell like
representations. So I'd be interested
to see how this idea of representational
structure can help us explain maybe more
than our scientific findings we're
finding as well and how this relates to
generative models as a whole. And then
finally, I think there's something to be
said about cognitive plausibility of
these models as well. Maybe we're not
just going to be testing them from a
neuroscience perspective, but also from
a cognitive science perspective. For
example, there's these Ravens
Progressive Matrices on the left where
you have to say which one of these
images is more likely to fit in this
pattern? Or for example, how likely is
it that this Jenga Tower falls over when
you pull a specific block or with a
given structure? And I think these
types of tests are really testing if our
world models that we're building are
similar to the types of models that we
innately have our own common sense as
humans or as beings living in a natural
world. And I've done some preliminary
work in this direction, I think very
preliminary and not nearly this
complicated, but trying to model visual
illusions. So if you take a really
simple data set of a moving bar stimuli
or a static bar frame and you move it a
little bit, you can see that the model
will actually infer that missing frame
and then actually also infer continued
motion. So it's like overshooting the
trajectory of what the actual stimuli is
providing it before correcting again.
So I think modeling illusions is
certainly an interesting way to study if
our world models are similar to the
types. Of models that we have ourselves.
So in conclusion, yeah, I think
topographic priors we could show that
they effectively learn structured
representations or structured world
models. This learned structure is
flexible and adaptable to arbitrary
transformations, unlike traditional
equivariance. And topographic riders can
be induced statistically as we did in
the topographic VAE or through dynamics
like we were showing in these neural
wave machine type models. So to
conclude, I'll leave you with this quote
that I found in Fukushima's paper from
1980 I thought was pretty far ahead of
its time, where he says, if we could
make a neural network model which has
the same capability for pattern
recognition as a human being, it would
give us a powerful clue to understanding
the neural mechanism in the brain. So
that's kind of, I think, some. Of the
goals that we're going for here. So I'll
say thanks to my advisor Max, my co
authors Patrick Yue, Emile Jinghe, and
Yorn, and interested in discussion.
Thanks.
All right, thank you. Great. Very
interesting presentation.
A lot of places to start. Maybe just
what brought you to this work, a little
context on how you came into this work
for your PhD direction.
Yeah, I mean, there's been studying
the group that I'm in at the university
has been studying structured
representations from mathematical point
of view for a while, and we're some of
the people to models. Or for the
variational auto encoder. And I
guess what something that had always
been the model that respects rotations,
2D rotations perfectly well. But if we
want to do 3D rotations, we can't do
that because that's not a group in terms
of a. Projection onto a 2D plane.
You're losing information when this
thing rotates. Around, for example.
Or just any sort of natural
transformations. Like I was trying to
point out at the beginning, I think it
was trying to think about how the brain
models natural transformations is
something that these. Current frameworks
where do you see action playing a role
in terms of variational, auto encoder
models that include not just external
patterns, but also the consequences of
action or world model structure with
action. Right,
yeah. No, it's a good question. And I
think active inference is effectively
I think it's a good answer to that.
I know there are reinforcement learning
frameworks that do use kind of
externally trained world models. So you
train a VAE or something and then you
use that representation in. Your
reinforcement learning system. But I
think having a fully kind of a system
that is a single. Objective with action
as part of the. Likelihood of the data,
I think that's much more elegant. I'm a
big proponent of that.
I have not gotten so far as to study how
these structured world models in a VAE
or I haven't worked. On that at all.
But I think it would certainly be very
interesting to see if having a. More
structured world model in a variational
auto encoder would be beneficial in an.
Active setting as well. I think that
would be awesome. I mean, I think some
of these examples, like, showing before,
like, emergence of. Grid cells and
things like this, maybe. Point towards
that direction of, hey, maybe the brain
is doing something. It really obviously
has a lot of structure. This clearly has
to be useful for performing actions in
some way. Cool. Yeah.
I thought a really nice parallel that
you brought in with the talk was the
locally connected units enabled
your models to structurally embody the
convolutional constraint and pattern,
and that led to these arising patterns.
And then analogously, there was the
Doral et al. Where they had
the path exploration constraint.
Right. And so then it's interesting to
think about these action or policy
heuristics or sparsities like a joint
motor exploration. Eventually it becomes
understood that there's like two
mutually opposing ways to move a joint,
and then the compositionality across
joints can be learned at these higher
levels once it's locked in at lower
levels. So it's a very appealing and
niche relevant way to generalize because
it's both based upon the actual
constraints of the world, but then
especially through action, potentially
embedding something that's quite simple.
Right? Yeah, no, I think that's
definitely true. That's a really good
point. If you do have constraints coming
from. Your actions themselves, then that
would be hugely beneficial for helping
to structure your latent space. And I
think yeah, I guess one thing I wanted
to mention there's something made me
think of, like, Stefano Fousey's work on
kind of the representational geometry
determines how
generalizable a given understanding of a
system is. And I think if you can
understand if these sets
of activities are separable or highly
parallel separable with a linear
classifier, essentially, then you're
going to be able to do generalization.
And I think by imposing these types of
biases or potentially through
constraints that are imposed by action,
something like this, you are yielding
or kind of inducing a better
representational geometry. And this has
all sorts of benefits for
compositionality or generalization.
It's a great point. Cool. Yeah. Very
interesting area. All right, I'll read
some questions from the live chat love
Evolve wrote any practical
or observed limitations on modeling
illusions?
Deep learning, community uses. They're
not foveated. You don't have a center of
gaze, and you also don't have most
convolutional neural networks. I'm using
these kind of recurrent neural networks,
but time is not as clearly defined in
these models as it is. In a continuous
time setting for human undergoing an
illusion trial. And I think the
combination of these two, of the fact
that as a human, for most things,
you're shifting locations and your gaze
are dependent on you looking to a
particular area, a lot. Of cognitive
science tests. And so I think it would
be really helpful if we had models that
you can think of this as a type of
action of learning where to move your
gaze. One of the simplest possible that
would help a lot for being able to model
illusions. And just I mean, for me,
it's like I read a paper of some
cognitive science experiments or about
some illusion, and I think of, okay,
can I put this data set into my model
and test it? And most of the time the
answer is no, because I don't have a.
Model that looks around or has a
restricted field of view, something like
that. So, yeah, I think that's one of
the limitations. Another one is makes
the experiment much more complicated.
So that's one of the practical
limitations. Wow. Great answer.
Makes me think of a paper with letters
rotating on a table. That's the digit
rotation. Great points about the
Foveation and the dynamics of the
illusion. I think you actually did
mention an illusion, which is however,
you mentioned in the generalization
context, which is rotating on the two
dimensional screen doesn't generalize to
three dimensions, and that dimensional
collapse or reduction is the basis of
the cube projection illusions and cube
and figure rotation illusions. It's on
your screen and there's a silhouette or
there's some ambiguous stimuli that
it's near a criticality or a bifurcation
in the generative model. So it could
represent it one way or another way.
And so a lot of the switching illusions
are just based upon the flatness of
images and the limitations
in generalization that are revealed by.
Some work sorry, there's some work where
they can argue people have a kind of
three dimensional. Image in their heads.
Like even Nancy Kenwich had her library
on this recently and showing yeah, I
don't know. Do our models have that?
It's not super clear anyway.
Yeah, that's pretty interesting. All
right. From Upcycle club in the chat,
they wrote Kudos. You're able to learn
nearly as effectively. If you imagine
you only want a single neuron to be
active for every example. Your model is
going to be trying to memorize the data
set to some. Extent or something like
this, and you're not going to have
enough capacity. So, yeah, I think
tuning that level. Of sparsity is
certainly an important factor.
And when you look at the likelihood,
if you're calling framework, typically
this is balanced automatically with the
likelihood itself. If you're not doing
generative modeling, you just have a
sparsity penalty. You're going to want
to tune that parameter. Okay. They added
just to clarify runaway behavior in
Armina, where the network becomes
unstable or chaotic due to various
factors such as feedback loops, noise,
or adversarial inputs.
Yeah, I guess I haven't looked at this
in a recurrent setting where you would
get feedback loops,
but I could see adversarial examples
being potentially affected by your level
of sparsity.
The interesting point is, would you be
more susceptible or less susceptible to
adversary examples? I don't know.
Well, sparsification projecting
from a fully connected, higher
dimensional model just into
progressively smaller it's pretty well
understood in general what the trade
offs are. It's easier computations, a
smaller model, sparser. The Bayes
graph is going to be clearer to
represent and then also it will have all
of the other trade offs with false
positive and negatives of generalizing.
But that's why it's an iterative fit
process. So I guess how does your
sparsification approach balance?
Does it use AIC or BIC or some other
model fitting approach to determine the
relevant sparsification for a given
input? How do you determine
in Lasso regression,
how do you threshold how many how sparse
you want it to be? Right, yeah,
I think there's a lot of good literature
on this, and even so, some people like
DembaBa at Harvard. And some people I'm
working with now have done these
kind of unrolled iterative
sparsification networks where it's like
a recurrent neural network and
iteratively sparsifies. And you can show
that this yields. Something like relus
or. Group sparse
activations like we're using here in
this setting. It's really just by having
this construction of this T variable
where we have Z on top and
then it's in some effect gated by
the sum of U variables in the bottom.
So, w maybe I wasn't super clear about
this is a matrix that is connecting.
That's what defines the groups when I'm
defining the group sparsity, that
connects all of these U's together. And
so the idea is like here.
If all of one of the other. Examples,
if all of your U's are not active
for a given T,
or if all of your U's are active for a
given T, that T variable is going to be
very small, right? Because your
denominator is going to be very big,
and that induces sparsity. So it's like
constraint satisfaction. If you have a
set of U's that are all small, then that
that constraint is satisfied. And now Z
is allowed to kind of express itself and
that's what then kind of
achieves the sparse activation. So this
is induced by these two KL divergence
terms here. These are saying like, how
far is each U and each Z from a
gaussian? And then through this
construction of the student T variable,
we're effectively constructing a sparse
prior distribution just from these
Gaussians. But in terms of the actual
objective, the terms and the objective
that we're optimizing are just these two
KL terms. That are pushing it towards
sparsity to some extent. And this is
balanced automatically with the.
Likelihood term here through the
decoder. So we don't have terms that
we're tuning, but we're learning the
parameters of. These different encoders
and then analyzing the failed urgencies.
Cool. All right. Another question from
Dave Douglas, who wrote speaking
of gaze and illusion. Can the studies on
constancies in infants be separated into
lower level illusion, relative, perhaps
higher level conceptual constancy?
Can you read the current kind of
architecture? Might the studies on
constancies in infants cognitive
constancies, be separated? Yeah,
probably. I'm not an
expert or actually even very familiar
with object permanency studies and.
Infants and constancy stuff, but I
think. That would be incredibly
interesting to study in neural network
architectures. And that was kind of some
of the idea with this illusion that I
was trying to model down here with this
line. I don't know if I was super clear
about this, but the top row is the
input, and we're effectively like
blocking the input for a single frame.
And I wanted to see, does the network
kind of encode that the thing is still
there when that frame is gone? Can I
still decode the presence of. The object
from the neural activity? And then what
is it also inferring about the motion
because of the fact that it saw the bars
at a. Slightly different location than
from before after the frame is gone.
So, yeah, I think there's definitely
multiple levels to it where some
would probably be much lower level and
maybe long term object permanency, I
would guess would. Be significantly
higher level. It just makes me
think of those. Experiments with cats
back in the day. Where it's like they
raised them in darkness except for an
hour a day. They put them in vertical
world or horizontal world where they
only saw horizontal lines or vertical
lines, and you can see the
organization of their cortex changes,
like they have less receptivity to
horizontal lines if they've never seen
horizontal lines before. And then you
take a stick and you wave it in front of
their face, and if the stick is
horizontal, they do nothing. If it's
vertical, they're swatting at it.
They'Re trying to hit it, it's like.
They just literally don't hunzle bar in.
Front of their face. So I think in that
case, then, this is evidence of a low
level efficiency in vision contributing
to some sort of an illusion. So I think,
yeah, there could certainly. Be some
aspect to that in infants as well.
One very curious point you brought up
was the animate and inanimate manifold
with small things being intermediate,
right? What does that represent?
Or is it because they're handleable or
it might be an insect or it might be
something that might move away just with
wind or what does that say?
Right, yeah, so this
is work by Talia Konkel,
I think was the one who discovered this
organization and they tried to figure it
out. I might be getting this wrong, so I
recommend people to read her work on
that. They call it Tripartite
organization. But if I remember
correctly, they did a lot of follow up
work on why there's this organization
and some evidence of curvature
of these objects and kind of like the
distance that you see objects from or
like animate objects are maybe
more curvy or regardless of what the
actual answer is, there were a lot of
different hypotheses that were stemming
from properties of these objects.
Maybe mid level or low level properties,
more so than higher level properties. I
still don't know if it's exactly been
solved of whether it's like,
interaction, like you said, with the
objects causes the separation or
the general shapes of these objects. I
would bet, as with most things, it's
like some combination of all of the
above. But I think the interesting thing
from this modeling point of view is that
this is only trained on correlation
statistics from the image data sets
itself. This has no interaction, this
has no notion of animacy.
I mean, this is really just training a
model on ImageNet, just images of dogs,
cats, boats, whatever, and yet it still
achieves this type of organization. So
there's some sort of it could be
semantic characteristics, right? We have
a network that can classify boats versus
dogs versus 20 other breeds of dogs,
but it might also have. Some
correspondence with lower level image
statistics as well. So? Yeah. I don't
know. I guess he's my answer.
Yeah. Provocative analogy was the
translational shift in the MNIST
in the handwriting recognition setting.
What are the translational shifts that
exist today? What's the three pixel
example? Is that some prompt engineered
attack on an Lom or something? Or
something. A special character being
inserted, or some overlay
on an image that we can't even detect.
So what do you think those challenges
are and what are ways that we can pursue
that? Yeah, absolutely.
I mean, I think kind of the way I was
thinking about it is like these symmetry
transformations. If you're
thinking about language models, you can
imagine a symmetry transformation is
just like replacing a word with a
synonym or something. You have the
sentence to us means the exact same
thing, but now suddenly. The model is
going to respond very differently.
Or like translation between languages,
this can. Be seen as a type of
transformation. It preserves the
underlying meaning of the input
to us, but to the model. It looks
completely different. And we would like
to have models which behave in a
predictable way with respect to these
types of transformations, because I
think humans behave very predictably
with the type of these transformations.
And when we're dealing with AI systems,
we expect them to also behave that way.
And I think that's part of what causes a
lot of challenges interacting with these
systems. And I kind of tried to do a
rough cheeky demonstration of that with.
This bear and squares and stuff.
We expect it to be able to do something
simple like this because we think most
humans could, and yet it doesn't. And if
you imagine this is a. Critical scenario
where you expect this, then that's a big
problem. How do we handle that? I think
that's kind of what I'm searching for.
I think. My direction
I'm taking it is look more simple,
kind of like bottom up building blocks
of neural network architectures or
algorithms that kind of yield these
emergent structural properties. And I
think that's a much more generalizable
way. Rather than building something on
top of. What we already have,
I think that's. Something that would
scale much better and. Also matches more
what the brain does.
Very cool. One kind of implementational
question. What are the computational
requirements of just running this, or
what's the day to day like of being a
student or researcher running variants
of these? Like, do they use terabytes of
data and you're using large computation?
Or is this something that people can run
on their own laptops? I think almost
everything I presented today can be run
locally. So this stuff is super simple.
You can run you
can run it on. Your laptop. If you want
to train and experiment with different
things, it's going to be pretty slow.
So I'd recommend some commercial GPU.
I run pretty much everything on like
Nvidia 1080s, pretty old, pretty cheap,
but they have twelve gigs of Ram or
whatever, and it's kind of more than
enough for these models. Gigabytes of
Ram I think one thing that some people
think is weird is I do most of my
experiments on stuff like MNIST. So it's
32 x 32 pixel images because I can train
it small. And locally, if you
want to do. Stuff, my experiments are on
mnists. If you want to do stuff like
this, these are much more complicated.
This Hamiltonian Dynamic suite here,
you're getting into bigger models that
are running across multiple GPUs. And so
here I was using a cluster to run these
types of models. But I say most of the
single machine with the GPU is more than
enough. Or even just like in a collab.
Notebook, something like that. If you
want to train something on ImageNet, it
gets more complicated and you need at
least one GPU, ideally more. But yeah,
I don't do a whole lot of big scale
stuff yet. I think it's certainly
interesting and there's definitely a lot
more you can do there. But for some of
these kind of simpler or more
fundamental questions, I don't. Know
what you want to call it. A smaller
machine is nice and fast.
Cool, useful. All right. I'll read
a comment from Dave recalling Bert
Devries'comment during the Applied
Active Inference Symposium about the
desirability of spending less effort or
ATP on foraging or control situations
where we don't need much precision. I
don't know if you listen to this, but
Professor DeVries mentioned about
variable precision models and how they
could be used to enable different
features of generalization and actual
structural course training as well as
reduced computational requirements.
Does he have any suggestions on how to
introduce this distinction into active
inference theory? What kinds of
experiments could winkle this out?
Oh, wow. Yeah, that's something I don't
think I have too much intelligence to
say about, to be completely honest.
Hmm. It's super interesting question
because I think the intuition makes a
lot of sense to me that you're talking
about, if I understand correctly,
variable rates of vision when you're
encoding or in your model in general,
doing computation that
somehow has an impact on your future
performance as a relation to some energy
store. I think if you wanted to build
this into an active inference system,
you would need to have really an
embodied system where the agent has some
notion. Of energy, like an internal
energy store, and.
Something that is trying to conserve
while it's performing its actions and
running out of energy would need to
mean. Something bad for the agent. And
then maybe you could observe kind. Of an
emergent reduction in
encoding precision or something like
this as the agent is trying to learn to
act more. Effectively, you might have to
give it. An ability to control its
precision. Yeah, like I say, out of
my thoughts.
Okay. On this slide right here, first,
very cool image. It's kind of like a
digital Jackson Pollock.
If it were a simpler input data size
or just reduced complexity of patterns,
or if it were an increased complexity,
how would this image look different?
Yeah, so I did some experiments trying
to change these orientation
columns and basically
changing the parameters of the model.
You can get these columns to be bigger.
You can get them to not have very
similar structure to what we see in the
humans, where you can get them to have
more bands of activity. And it
also, like you said, it depends on the
data set that you're using. If I use
really simple sinusoidal gradings as
input, I get something like this. I get
something that's a little bit more
rotational, curvy, higher entropy.
So I think these are all interesting
things if you want to study the
emergence of this type of organization
in a natural system. If you have a model
that now yields different organization
for different settings that see,
okay, then what settings best match our
observed data?
I can send those around if you're
interested. But I
think one other interesting point there
is that the different animals and types
of orientation selectivity and
different numbers of pinwheels. Some
animals don't have it at all. I think
maybe mice, if I'm correct, have this
kind of they call it salt and pepper
selectivity. So it's basically random.
You don't have any sort of, like,
topographic orientation selectivity. So
there is evidence that different
systems. Do this differently, and it's
interesting to figure out why. Yeah,
this very cool. It reminds me of,
first, the reaction diffusion,
space and time. So it's actually
possible that a region might have no
activity from a given granularity,
like if it was being looked at at fMRI
spatial and temporal timescale.
But if the pockets of activity are
slower, faster, then that measurement
is going to not be different than noise.
It'll all have been averaged out.
So then there might be some interesting
data sets that do actually have a lot of
richness, but then for one reason or
another, it just was averaged out over
because it wasn't being connected. To
you or something like this. You really
need to go at the single trial level.
You need to have high enough spatial
resolution such that it satisfies
Nyquist frequencies.
And this just is something that people
didn't do for a long time, especially if
you're doing single electrode
recordings. You're not going to see a
traveling wave. You're going to see
oscillations. You need, like, multi
electrode arrays. And basically they're
saying, okay, yeah, now that we have the
technology to do. This, it's much
resists that we didn't see before. And
potentially, this is an explanation for
a lot of the noise that we were seeing
before. Maybe it really is just
traveling waves. So yeah,
I think there's a lot to be done in the
future with. Increased abilities for
recording. That's very cool.
Well, any final thoughts or questions or
where are you going to take this work?
Yeah, no. Thanks for having me.
Hopefully in the active infrastructure
direction. I would love to. I think
it'll be super fun. So yeah, I'm not
really sure. I'm looking at maybe music
right now, looking at
other kind of crazy directions.
I don't want to sound too crazy,
but I'll go down. Yeah, a lot of things.
So one thing that's coming up,
something we submitted to Neurops is
studying memory with traveling waves.
So that paper just came out on. Archive
today of how waves are really good at
encoding long term memories, which. I
think is super interesting. So I might
go a little more in that direction.
Sounds good. And yes, would be very
exciting to see action come into play
when there was the neurons that stayed
active even as the dog's feet were
moving. There's a lot of action
sequences, like throwing a baseball,
and then it goes, and it's like there's
something about that action that's
continuing to influence it's to having,
like, a deep temporal representation of
alternative actions.
And then the variational auto encoder is
already basically the right anything
like that. Really appreciate it.
All right, thank you. Till next time.
Thanks so much.